the Academy Awards will be here before
we know it February 28th on ABC and if
there's one thing you got to get right
after calling out all the correct names
the winners it is the food and luckily
they have Hollywood's master chef in
control Wolfgang Puck and he led our
Samantha Harris in his kitchen for the
first look at what he's got cook it up
for the Oscars most exclusive party so
we have a lemon meringue pie you have to
be very careful well it's not that toy
for kids maybe but no it's okay yeah 600
lemon meringue pies 200 rocks blam
thousand lobsters pert buy 300 of
Wolfgang's best chefs are any of the
food items themed attics in the films
that are nominated you know not really
we don't sell any pears or anything like
that
yeah I'd think so but Leo loves to taste
different things when he comes to
sparkle he always eats like a tasting
menu it said I don't want to eat one
thing
rounding out the luxury 30 pounds of
caviar and $20,000 with the French black
truffles and here's another number
10,000 as in flowers that's how many
mark health co-owner of mark's garden
has ordered for the Governor's Ball and
all in one color that just kind of
occurred to us we've never done white in
a year when the hashtag Oscars so white
is perhaps the Academy's biggest concern
turns out it's an unfortunate
coincidence we begin the designs on the
flowers about six months prior to the
ball we know the flowers we're gonna be
using we decided on the colors mark top
four cotton seeking only the freshest
blooms from Holland we have lilac he's
amazing
amazing ranunculus grown for us in Japan
these wonderful gardenias for fragrance
this is going to be amazing in the boobs